That's all for now. Shiro and I will
wait in the other world first. After the enemy dies, we'll take him with us. I can't go
right away either. You have to live. Live and
protect your roots.
Ahano,
demon slayer,
this is a first for us.  The
Japanese
government's actions are the biggest challenge for Japan,
so why not use that luck once again for justice?It
seems like the Higashiyama family is
telling a story that is not true.  It looks like he's
doing [music] to a gathering of sick people. I
can't leave the demon slayer alone.
Seeing him doing that, he's perfectly human.
Risk is stopping me.  You're the first one to do it
[Music] I
can't let go of my role If everyone dies, I ca
n't lie to myself and say I was still alive Can you please leave me alone? I
'll hunt my prey.  Why do we have to
do this because it's so fun?
Of course we're going to put our best foot forward for the sake of our family,
but we've gone to a secret place where we're not doing anything.
Now you're going to be hunted.